طلع الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي
ستورمبرج ان رساله منظومات دفاع جوي من
طراز باتريوت الى اوكرانيا كانت معروضه
على وارسو مشيرا لانه قرار يجب ان توافق
عليه دول محدده ويخضع لمشاورات بين اعضاء
الحلف صوت البرج اضافه في مؤتمر صحفيين في
بروكسل قبل اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه دول حلف
شمال الاطلسي في بوخارست الاسبوع المقبل
ان نيته سيواصلوا دعمه لاوكرانيا مهما
استغرق ذلك من وقت مؤكدا ان دعم اوكرانيا
هو افضل سبيل لتحقيق حل سلبي للحرب
نور
لن يكون هناك سلام دائم اذا انتصر المعتدي
معظم الحروب تنتهي بمفاوضات لكن ما يحدث
على طاوله المفاوضات يعتمد على ما يقع في
ميدان المعركه ولذلك فان افضل السبل
لتعزيز فرص التوصل الى حل سلمي دعم
اوكرانيا
سيواصل تضامنه مع اوكرانيا مهما استغرق
ذلك الوقت
خلال اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه الحلف في
رومانيا
سبورت يقدم الحلفاء بدعما عسكريا غير
مسبوق و اتوقع من وزراء الخارجيه مزيدا من
الدعم غير العسكري يقدم بالفعل دعم
لوجيستيا بتوفير الوقود والادويه واجهزه
التشويش على المسايرات
ساطلب المزيد على المدى الطويل ستساعد
اوكرانيا في التحول من المعدات من العهد
الصوفيتي الى العصر الحديث وفقا لمعايير